la ciudad declamador se está
convirtiendo en una especie de ciudad
fantasma donde cada día más y más
personas se están marchando ya no
solamente los refugiados que se han
marchado porque estaban en una zona de
guerra o la gente de dones y lugares que
esperan una inminente operación rusa en
esta región sino que aquí en clamatos
después de lo que ocurrió en la estación
de tren la gente ha dicho basta la gente
tiene miedo y simplemente se están
marchando no saben a dónde ir y lo único
que quieren es marcharse a un lugar
seguro
ahora estamos muy asustados con todo lo
que está pasando pero después de la
tragedia en la estación decidimos
marcharnos iniesta alcarràs bone y
marchena pase materia no sabemos a dónde
ir odiamos a los rusos
decidí huir después del ataque con
misiles tosca en la estación de tren si
nos invaden las tropas rusas no quiero
vivir bajo su ocupación
estable
autobuses y microbuses como estos se han
convertido en la última esperanza para
los pocos civiles que todavía quedan
aquí en crema tours y que marcharán a la
región de nijni pro que se ha convertido
en un centro estratégico para la llegada
y evacuación de refugiados